this is the moment a hundred million
pound criminal Empire crumbled
35 year old TJ Fletcher is arrested by
police after the biggest fraud operation
in British history
I will be showing you how to call any
number worldwide from any caller ID
using ice boof his website I spoof gave
fraudsters the tools to impersonate
Banks and other trusted institutions at
its peak it had nearly 60 000 users
making millions of scam calls
various price plans were offered
depending on the level of deception
required all of which earned Fletcher
alone nearly 2 million pounds that he
used to buy luxury cars and watches
profiting from the misery of others
fraud is not a victimless crime and the
cost to the many victims in this case
has not just been Financial
it's also had a huge emotional in
freem distress and Devastation to those
affected many of whom had their bank
accounts emptied and their life savings
stolen from them Fletcher marketed his
services on the social media app
telegram we've accessed his channel
which is still online have a look at
some of these messages here he's
offering admin support as though it's
any kind of normal internet business as
well as posting slick marketing videos
advertising his services to potential
clients ice Booth was made by spoofers
for spoofers pick up it's not a new
threat fraud has existed for a lot
longer than computers have and in many
instances people kind of brush it off
thinking that they're not an interesting
person or maybe they might think they're
not particularly wealthy they don't have
a lot of a lot of money to steal or
those kinds of things but that doesn't
mean that they won't be targeted
police uploaded their own spoofed
mimicking Fletcher's marketing style to
warn those using his Services you made a
bad call the police will be seeing you
soon so far 169 such people have been
arrested this record investigation has
much further left to run Matthew
Thompson Sky News